[Music]
foreign
Bad Company corrupts good character
culture makes all men gentle
he who labors diligently need never
despair for all things are accomplished
by diligence and labor
[Music]
the sword the body wounds sharp words
the mind
[Music]
the chief beginning of evil is goodness
in excess
we live not as we wish to but as we can
old men are children for the second time
whom the God's love dies Young
I call a fig a fig a spade a spade
[Music]
marriage if one will face the truth is
an evil but a necessary one
[Music]
the man who runs May fight again
it is not white hair that engenders
wisdom
[Music]
a thing hard to track is Fortune
spoken word is man's physician in grief
for this alone has soothing charms for
the soul
to refrain from all Injustice renders us
also humane
let bravery be thy choice but not
bravado
[Music]
thank you
riches cover a multitude of woes
know thyself is a good saying but not in
all situations in many it is better to
say no others
it is always best to tell the truth at
every crisis I recommend this as a chief
contribution to Security in life
God lends a hand to honest boldness
the person who has the will to undergo
while labor may win any goal
[Music]
the truth sometimes not sought for comes
forth to the light
intelligence if it is clever in the
direction of the better is responsible
for the greatest benefits of all
[Music]
School of Hard Knocks is an accelerated
curriculum
and must be prepared for every event of
life for there is nothing that is
durable
[Music]
know thyself means this that you get
acquainted with what you know and what
you can do
if you want to live your whole life free
from Pain you must become either a God
or a corpse
[Music]
mortal never pray for an untroubled life
but ask the gods to give you an enduring
heart
foreign
this know yourself is a silly proverb in
some ways to know the man next door is a
much more useful rule
[Music]
what a wonderful being is the man if he
is a man
[Music]
how sweet is life when Fortune is not
envious
how big is the little thing that was
given at the right time
respect old age for it does not come
alone
time is the Healer of all the inevitable
ills
always keep in mind that things change
remember the favor you have received and
forget the favor you have given
[Music]
to make the same mistake twice is not
wise
a fair man never becomes rich
health and intellect are the two
blessings of life
any man who blushes is a good man me
thinks
shyness is the Citadel of beauty
[Music]
nobody knows what you think but
everybody sees what you do
the tongue has led many men to
destruction
[Music]
time tests friends like fire tests gold
time leads truth toward the light
a slip of the tongue speaks the truth
[Music]
silence alone is not an apology
always avoid the company of a vicious
man
it is always better to tell the truth
[Music]
when you take give back and you will
take again
there is safety in moderation
a wicked woman is a depository of
disaster
[Music]
while you do what you have to do don't
pay attention to what others are doing
loans make slaves out of free men
if you associate with bad people you
will become one
if we have money we shall have friends
[Music]
a good wife is the Salvation of a man's
life
if your actions have a just cause you
will have the gods as allies
[Music]
the root of Misfortune is pleasure
seeking
there is no man who does not blame his
luck
don't punish anyone without
investigating
a wrong word can turn your whole life
upside down
inappropriate laughter is bad luck
the mob is powerful and has no sense
we all want to get rich but we cannot
everything is achievable through
diligence and effort
[Music]
necessity makes everybody stronger
Prudence is a depository of virtue
a handsome person with perverted will is
a fine craft that's handled without
skill
artists man's Refuge from adversity
[Music]
all men have one Refuge a good friend
with whom you can weep and know that he
does not smile
nothing has happened to you unless you
make much of it
[Music]
it must be that evil Communications
corrupt good dispositions
of all the wild beasts of land or sea
the wildest is woman
the truth not sought for comes forth to
the light
[Music]
no just person never became quickly rich
to live is not to live for oneself let
us help one another
no man alive can say this shall not
happen to me
[Music]
the good man makes others good
nothing is more useful than silence
at times Discretions should be thrown
aside and with the foolish we should
play the fool
by associating with wise people you will
become wise yourself
never ask the gods for Life set free
from grief but ask for courage that
endureth grief
sleep is a healing bomb for every ill
[Music]
chance is a kind of God for it preserves
many things which we do not observe
[Music]
hope saves a person in the midst of
misfortune
you live a good life if you don't have a
wife
[Music]
the character of a man is known from his
conversation
[Music]
nothing bad will happen to you by
distrusting your enemies
nobody loves anybody more than himself
women know nothing except what they want
foreign
[Music]
for all women silence is beauty
the Workman is still greater than his
work
[Music]